un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
un gusto saludarles desde parís para
este carrusel de las artes especiales en
el que recibimos a un artista que ha
vencido las dificultades y todas las
restricciones para estar aquí en
nuestros estudios el día de hoy el
pianista cubano omar sosa en carrusel de
las artes hola omar muchísimas gracias
por darnos el honor de tenerte aquí en
marzo hasta hoy en carrusel de las artes
[Música]
east african journey un día en áfrica
del este es el más reciente trabajo de
marzo sa y de eso vamos a hablar en esta
ocasión este disco que tengo aquí en mis
manos es una aventura comenzada en una
gira en 2009 donde conociste omar a
varios músicos de esos países de esa
región de áfrica del este y el resultado
el fruto de estos encuentros con
diferentes instrumentistas es este disco
con 13 temas
[Música]
y
e
estamos escuchando uno de los temas de
este disco se asociará con el malgache
de ayer y el príncipe según del val y de
ese instrumento que acabamos de ver
cuéntanos omar cómo fueron esos
encuentros con estos músicos
tradicionales en áfrica bueno todo
empezó como bien adición a una gira en
2009 por ocho países de áfrica del este
y gracias a la alianza francesa mi
agencia y a mí ya mi compañía de
managers de managers pudimos poner a
todos estos músicos
juntos y debo decir que ha sido uno de
los mejores momentos de mi vida sino el
mejor momento hasta ahora compartir con
ellos en sus en su tierra natal con sus
comidas y bueno salió este este proyecto
que en mi opinión es como
eso como un pasaporte un pasaporte de
asia
hacia ese mundo que llevo siempre dentro
de esa fría
pero un explorador musical en todos tus
discos están explorando ese arte que es
el tuyo que es la música porque en este
disco te centras te en estos países de
áfrica les es bueno siempre siempre que
hablamos de áfrica
lo primero que hablamos es de áfrica del
norte o si no de hoy del estero de
sudáfrica
senegal mali sudáfrica pero yo había
estado en la en la en la que es bueno
fui enviado por el cuerpo del gobierno
cubano
a la la guerra en angola
y etiopía y cuando estuve ahí siempre me
quedó la duda de qué pasa musicalmente
aquí y finalmente gracias a la alianza
francesa como ha dicho anteriormente
pude llegar a estos países pero
básicamente lo que me interesa es tratar
de buscar a músicos que tocan
instrumentos de cuerdas y cantas en a la
misma vez porque siempre que hablamos de
áfrica
hablamos de percusión de baile a ritmo
ritmo y de bueno y áfrica no sólo es
ritmo también es melodía y
afortunadamente bueno se vive estado
esta posibilidad y uno ya está en esa
fricción y un viaje por el este de
áfrica y fíjate que escuchando este
disco pues nos hace es conocer
instrumentos por ejemplo la vall y del
que hablamos madagascar un haití de
kenia en sudán el tambor en etiopía el
crear en burundi el humor y el calumbo
de zambia que además es el ancestro del
berimbau que se da
qué se utiliza en la capoeira es decir
que es un testimonio tu disco de esa
riqueza musical que hay en áfrica yo
para mí fue lo mismo y recuerdo que
cuando cuando llegamos a hamada a
madagascar que fue el 1er
la primera parada así y veo agarra ayer
y yo yo yo conocía a roger y desde aquí
de parís y para mí fue como como veis el
opening fue perfecto dijo le pero pero
tú no vives en parís pero yo vivo aquí y
yo soy de mascardi goles ok yo pensaba
que el que la valía era de otro de otro
lugar y a partir de ese momento después
cuando entré omonia más en llamas a fala
él fue como ir descubriendo instrumentos
uno por uno
y sonidos completamente nuevos que me
transportaron también a sonoridades
nuestra del mundo desde nuestra parte
afro caribeña también fuerte y muy
potente porque por ejemplo en venezuela
ellos hay un instrumento que es como el
bilbao pero pero pero al revés
y acto seguido cuando ya escuché eso
digo lenguado esto me recuerda algo que
hemos hecho con gustavo en tubo y si
para mí fue fue algo
me reveló muchas cosas y a partir de
ahora lo que he sentido es que tengo que
seguir en ese camino porque esa es mi
misión en esa exploración y bueno te
propongo que escuchemos otro extracto de
este de este disco con una
instrumentista o literat ego kenia tuvo
un moco loca quien toca el night y ti
[Música]
m
su homóloga de olid ra tengo quien toca
el night y tío omar sosa estos
instrumentos tú lo decías antes han sido
para ti un descubrimiento pero también
uno uno se sorprende quizás veces de la
simpleza de son son instrumentos hechos
con madera con cuerda con una calabaza
es decir que desde siempre el hombre ha
tratado de hacer música y más en áfrica
es la base por ejemplo él
le llama a este instrumento 20 pero
también le llama ocup
y él creó el instrumento
basado en la tradición y si y si miras
el instrumento de ese las y de michelle
y etiopía el crack es más o menos el
mismo el mismo concepto es la boca dice
una calabaza con cuerdas pero lo
interesante es cómo lo tocan cada uno y
la afinación que le ponen para mí te
digo que fue una revelación y bueno ya
llevo yo llevo muchos años en esta en
esta búsqueda en este intentando ir
intentando
yo diría que buscaron un diálogo
constante con mi mundo ancestral y mis
espíritus y mis ancestros en luz y a
través de este proyecto he entrado mucho
más en una tradición que yo no conocía
es por ejemplo yo como te comenté antes
estuve en etiopía en la guerra y a mí
cuando cuando me veía me decía me decían
por favor no hables porque tú pareces
somalí
y la guerra de esther eran con los
pero no no entendía por qué y yo tengo
mi físico
esto para ccoo somalí pues no soy somalí
o sicarios niño pero también soy
africano
es la raíz es la raíz mamá áfrica y
ahora como como integrante tú el piano
con todos estos instrumentos que son
tradicionales lo recuerdo como se como
cómo pudiste tú entrar para proponer
esto estos 13 temas que están en en este
disco y como ellos aceptaron también que
entraras con tu propia música contó el
propio estilo bueno
para empezar al principio cuando cuando
hablamos con ellos que fue bastante
difícil por el problema de idiomas ya
sabía que lo que supuestamente debía
suceder y con mucho toque en vivo en los
países y otros de concreto que con cela
así como él y también tocamos toque
comentar y fue fue muy fue fue muy
bonito porque cuando tuve la grabación
de lectura
yo tuve 98 años
intentando ver cómo ponía mis mis
especies dentro de ese plato que ya
estaba hecho
qué es lo que podía hacer no podía poner
más ajo cebolla porque ya era perfecto y
gracias a mi productor steve airways que
es inglés pero afincado aquí en parís el
en 2018
con una buena botella de vino y un buen
queso decidimos el punto es menos es más
y ahí está rico tomar una última
pregunta porque ya se nos acaba el
tiempo como has vivido tú esta epidemia
tú nos ofreces un viaje musical por
áfrica del este y en este momento no
podemos viajar
no podemos tener contactos como ha sido
este año para marzo bueno ni ellos
pueden venir aquí para mí bueno como
para todos ha sido un poco difícil pero
a la misma vez ha sido una un momento
creativo como nunca
cuando empezó la pandemia en el primer
confinamiento que cerraron todo yo
empecé a escribir día y noche como si no
fuese a vivir nunca más y hasta el día
de hoy sigo escribiendo y sigo tratando
de decir lo que mi alma y mi espíritu
quieren decir a través mío porque
tenemos que ser optimistas
hay luz tenemos que buscar la luz y
tenemos que seguir dando lo mejor de
nosotros esa es nuestra misión no
importa que haya pandemia o lo que sea
tenemos que seguir adelante no nos queda
otra que bueno te propongo que ese
optimismo que hay en la música lo
pasemos en este momento en carrusel de
las artes hemos preparado el piano de
nuestro programa para ti muchísimas
gracias omar por haber estado con
nosotros nosotros les agradecemos por su
sintonía y los dejamos con un tema de
omar sosa nene la cano muchísimas
gracias y escuchamos a marzo gracias
[Música]
ah
y
[Música]